[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halallweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Rudi zerne mit
viel Wintersport ja schönen guten Abend
hallo schauen wir auf die
Nachrichtenthemen dieses
freitags Deiche drohen zu brechen
ztausende Helfer im Einsatz in den
Hochwassergebieten unterstützen jetzt
auch Bundespolizei und
Bundeswehr russische Angriffswelle auf
Ukraine Kiev meldet die schwersten
Luftschläge seit Beginn des
Krieges und furiose Aufholjagd beim
Slalom Weltcup Lena Dürr holt sich in
lien den zweiten
Platz in den Hochwassergebieten hat sich
die Lage z.B in Dresden entspannt
anderen Orts herrscht weiter
Ausnahmezustand Niedersachsen hat die
Bundeswehr um Hilfe gebeten das ganze
Land steht unter Wasser und weiterer
Regen droht etwa 100.000 Einsatzkräfte
arbeiten seit Tagen um sie vor weiteren
Belastungen zu schützen bitten die
Behörden auf privates Feuerwerk zu
verzichten Sandra
teis das Wasser kam in der Nacht stieg
immer höher perden an der aller Teile
der Altstadt sind überflutet mit
Sandsäcken versuchen Anwohner ihre
Häuser zu schützen hier vorne haben wir
schon genug Sandsäcke hingehauen bin ich
der Meinung und jetzt werden wir noch
mehr Sandsäcke von hinten holen und
hinten die allerseite zu betonieren mit
boten werden Menschen in Sicherheit
gebracht Sandsäcke transportiert man
hilft sich gegenseitig so gut es eben
geht die Aussichten nicht gut leider die
Erwartung sind dass noch mehr Wasser
kommt wir hoffen dass nicht so viel
kommt aber wir gehen leider von
steigenden PG noch aus der Stadtteil
eislist ganz von Wasser umschlossen ein
fair Service wurde eingerichtet um die
Anwohner zu versorgen
wie hier in Meppen kämpfen Einsatzkräfte
in vielen Teilen Niedersachsens
erbittert darum dass die Deiche nicht
brechen im hattener Stadtteil Sandkrug
flogen Bundespolizei und Bundeswehr
sogenannte Big Bags an einen Deich der
nur noch aus der Luft zu erreichen ist
die Lage im Land ist laut
Landesregierung so angespannt wie nie
zuvor die Lage bleibt ernst und es ist
sicher eine der größten Hochwasser
Katastrophen vor allem weil sie so
landesweit ist gleichzeitig aber
schließe ich mich dem großen Dank an an
die vielen Helferinnen und Helfer auch
in Hoden Haagen droht der Deich zu
brechen das Wasser bedroht den Ort und
den nah gelegenen Tierpark das Haus der
Antilopen und Giraffen ist von Wasser
umschlossen jetzt wird überlegt wie die
Tiere in Sicherheit gebracht werden
können und Entspannung ist nicht in
Sicht nach einer kurzen Beruhigung
morgen soll es ab Sonntag wieder regnen
besonders betroffen ist auch der Norden
von Bremen wo zahlreiche Menschen ihre
Häuser verlassen mussten das niedrig
gelegene Land dort ist von Flüsschen und
Kanälen durchzogen und die Wassermassen
durchweichen jetzt die Deiche von Wümme
und wörpe was die Menschen in
Stadtteilen wie Bremen Borgfeld und im
benachbarten Liliental erleben zeigt
David
römheld bange Stunden des Wartens für
familiebänder aus Bremen Borgfeld Ihre
Heizung ist gerade ausgefallen wenn
jetzt auch noch der Strom abgestellt
wird steht nicht nur die Pumpe still sie
müssen auch ihr Haus räumen seit Heilig
Abend kämpfen sie hier gegen das Wasser
beängstigend beschissen Kräfte zerrend
müde ausgelaucht einfach kaputt alle Z D
Stunden nachts aufstehen gucken wie weit
ist die Pumpe wie ist das Wasser wie
hoch steht es bleiben oder gehen die
direkten Nachbarn mussten ihre Häuser
bereits verlassen genau wie mehr als 300
Menschen im benachbarten
in der Nacht zu Donnerstag aus dem
Gebiet um diese mehr Familienhäuser
evakuiert werden die Lage weiterhin
angespannt der Deich ist an mehreren
Stellen beschädigt die Wassermassen
Drücken von außen darauf die Gemeinde
muss Gerüchte um vermeintliche
Evakuierungen dementieren und auch
Sandsäcke kommen
abhanden insgesamt laufen die
Vorbereitungen auf einen möglichen
Deichbruch in Liliental gut auch dank
der Hilfe vieler Freiwilliger das
Problem die Stände nagen auf Dauer an
der Substanz des Teiches das Wasser
weicht den auf spült das Sediment heraus
dann wird das der Teich so puddingartig
und das haben wir hier an der Stelle
gehabt und wenn ein gewisser kritischer
Punkt erreicht ist dann wird's halt
wirklich gefährlich Maßnahmen wie
Sandsäcke seien ausgeschöpft es bleibe
nur hoffen und sich aufs Wasser
vorbereiten um die Einsatzkräfte zu
entlasten hat die Gemeinde für Silvester
ein böllerverbot verhängt den
Jahreswechsel wollte Familie Bänder im
Urlaub verbr bringen immerhin sie haben
zur Stunde noch Strom und können vorerst
in ihrem Haus
bleiben viel zu viel Wasser damit geht
ein Jahr zu Ende das durch zahlreiche
wetterxtreme geprägt war insgesamt war
2023 in Deutschland das wärmste Jahr
seit Beginn der Wetteraufzeichnungen
2,4° über dem langjährigen
Vergleichswert dabei dominierten dieses
Mal nicht Trockenheit und Hitzewellen
sondern feuchte Wärme mit viel Regen
Peter Wagner
berichtet eines war 2023 in Deutschland
keinesfalls zu trocken ein neujährliches
Wetterjahr der extreme mit stürmen Hagel
und Starkregen alle Orten öffnet der
Himmel seine Schleusen nie gesehene
Regenmengen überfluten in kürzester Zeit
im Juni die Kassel der Innenstadt die
Folge enorme Schäden für Mensch Natur
und Infrastruktur das Jahr 2023 war das
wärmste Jahr seit Begin der
Wetteraufzeichnungen in Deutschland und
global es war ein sehr nasses Jahr aber
es war sogar ein relativ
sonnenscheinreiches Jahr immer mehr
Wärme in der Atmosphäre Trockenheit wie
in Kanada ein Funke genügt und in den
Wäldern bricht das Inferno aus der
Himmel verdunkelt sich monatelang
Feuerwehren sind weitgehend machtlos wie
hier in Portugal die USA werden im
Frühjahr von mehr als 50 monstertornados
heim gesucht ganze Städte sind zerstört
es gibt Tote und Verletzte im Herbst
trifft Tropensturm Otis mit verheerender
Wucht den touristenehnsuchtsort Acapulco
in
Mexiko und überall öffnet der Himmel
seine Schleusen gigantische Regenmengen
in kürzester Zeit rund ums Mittelmeer
Dämme brechen in Griechenland und in
libien dort ertrinken tausende Menschen
in den
Schlammmassen wenn so viel Wärme im Meer
ist verdunstet eben auch viel Wasser
diese Feuchtigkeit kommt dann auch zu
uns und dann kann es zu extrem
Wetterereignissen kommen und wir
beobachten das ja wir hatten zuerst viel
Regen dann viel Schnee und jetzt
Tauwetter und noch ein Rekord im
Wetterjahr niemals fiel so viel Schnee
in so kurzer Zeit wie Anfang Dezember in
München die wetterbilanz Online haben
wir die Fakten noch mal zusammengefasst
in der ZDF heute App dort können Sie
auch nachsehen wie sich die Temperaturen
in Ihrer Stadt oder ihrem Landkreis in
den vergangenen 100 Jahren entwickelt
haben der Vorstoß von Arbeitsminister
Heil zu schärferen Sanktionen beim
Bürgergeld stößt auf ein geteiltes Echo
Zustimmung gibt's von CDU und FDP
Sozialverbände nennen die Pläne
kontraproduktiv ab Januar bekommen
alleinstehende bürgergeldempfänger 563 €
pro Monat wer zumutbare Arbeit mehrfach
ablehnt dem soll der Satz künftig bis zu
zwei Monate komplett gestrichen werden
für Wohnen und heizen zahlt der Staat
weiter Frank
Buchwald Bürgergeld das sollte so viel
freundlicher klingen als Harz 4 nun aber
kommt aus dem Arbeitsministerium ein
Vorschlag streng und hart wie früher wer
zumutbare Arbeit wiederholt ablehn soll
sanktioniert werden Sozialverbände
laufen Sturm wenn Menschen Jobangebote
ablehnen dann geschieht das oft weil sie
gar nicht in der Lage sind darauf zu
reagieren sie sind gerade in der
psychischen Krise oder könn nicht
richtig und lesen und schreiben und
dadurch verschlimmert sich ihre
Situation schon jetzt können Jobcenter
den Regelsatz abgestuft um bis zu 30%
kürzen nun soll eine neue Sanktion
hinzukommen die komplette Streichung für
zwei Monate wenn Arbeitslose partou
keine Arbeit annehmen wollen nur die
Miete wde weitergezahlt die Opposition
sieht sich
bestätigt SPD und Grünen ging es vor
allen Dingen um einen neuen Namen und
höhere Leistungen wir haben immer gesagt
der Grundsatz fordern und fördern und
das macht der Harz 4 aus darf nicht in
Zweifel gezogen werden Zustimmung auch
vom Koalitionspartner FDP Solidarität
ist keine Einbahnstraße deshalb ist es
richtig dass wir als Solidargemeinschaft
auch Gegenleistungen einfordern und wer
zumutbare Gegenleistungen ablehnt der
muss das auch zu spüren bekommen
tatsächlich handel es sich nur um sehr
wenige Fälle heißt es aus dem
Ministerium die große Mehrheit der
Arbeitslosen nehmen Jobangebote
bereitwillig
an noch mal zur Dimension bundesweit
waren laut Bundesagentur für Arbeit
zuletzt stand August rund 24 000
bürgergeldempfänger sanktioniert mehr
als 80% davon wegen terminversäumnissen
ohne wichtigen Grund und nur ein
Bruchteil wegen mehrfacher
Verweigerung in die USA es ist der
zweite Dämpfer innerhalb kurzer Zeit für
Ex-Präsident Trump nach Colorado hat ihn
nun auch der US-Bundesstaat Main von den
Vorwahlen seiner republikanischen Partei
ausgeschlossen die zuständige
Wahlleiterin begründete das mit der
Rolle Trumps bei der Erstürmung des
Kapitols
2021 Trump kündigte an gegen die
Entscheidung juristisch
vorzugehen die Ukraine meldet die
heftigsten Luftangriffe seit Beginn des
Krieges mit mindestens 30 Toten und mehr
als 100 Verletzten laut Militär feuerte
Russland fast 160 drohen und Raketen ab
der Beschuss galt großen Städten überall
im Land getroffen wurden viele zivile
Ziele in
etwa attackierte Russland auch eine
Geburtsklinik von dort berichtet Alisa
jung ein schwarzes Loch klafft im Apollo
Einkaufszentrum in nipr getroffen bei
einem der heftigsten Luftangriffe auf
die Ukraine seit Kriegsbeginn
Apothekerin Larissa kun war gerade auf
dem Weg zur
Arbeit ich sah wie die Rakete flog wie
sie explodierte alles vor meinen Augen
das ist schrecklich man weiß nicht was
man tun
sollen
auf der anderen Straßenseite ist eine
Klinik das Geburtshaus hier brante
völlig aus es wurden alle notwendigen
Kräfte und Einsatzfahrzeuge zuerst
dorthin geschickt weil sich dort
Gebärende und Säuglinge
befanden im gesamten Land gibt es Tote
und Verletzte war es Vergeltung für das
russische Kriegsschiff was die Ukraine
vor wenigen Tagen getroffen hat für die
Menschen hier spielt das keine Rolle
hier ist es ein Einkaufszentrum in
anderen stten sind Wohnhäuser russland
hat mit fast allen Waffentypen die Sie
zu bieten haben auf Zivilisten in der
gesamten Ukraine gezählt die einmal
wieder ihr zu Hause aufbauen und
weitermachen müssen trotz der Angst dass
so etwas gleich morgen wieder passieren
könnte als ich die Situation etwas
entspannte und sich der Rauch des Feuers
verzogen hatte raffte ich mich zusammen
und kam her um aufzuräumen das Leben
geht ja
weiter die Apotheke von Larissa klikun
hatte auch heute den ganzen Tag
geöffnet beim russischen Beschuss wurde
auch der NATO Luftraum verletzt nach
Angaben der polnischen Armee hat eine
russische Rakete 3 Minuten lang Polen
überflogen bevor sie dann den Luftraum
Richtung Ukraine wieder verlassen habe
die NATO teilte danach mit man bleibe
wachsam und verfolge die
Situation Israel geht weiter massiv in
Gaza vor im Süden in der Stadt
hananjunes vermutet das Militär die
Spitze der Terrororganisation Hamas
deshalb will die Armee die Offensive in
diesem Bereich noch ausweiten trotz der
hohen Zahl ziviler Opfer auch in Israel
löst das Vorgehen mittlerweile Kritik
aus Henriette de
mier noch sind es wenige die sich am
Abend in Tel Aviv versammeln für Frieden
demonstrieren und diesen Krieg Israels
in Frage stellen doch die Kritik sie ist
da vergangene Woche versammelten sich
Tausende Menschen die gegen die
Regierung und den Ministerpräsidenten
auf die Straße gingen er richtet mehr
Schaden als Nutzen an und er hat das
Volk verraten wir wollen dass er geht
die Regierung hat ihre Bürger im Stich
gelassen auf jede erdenkliche Weise von
Fragen der grundlegenden Sicherheit bis
hin zu demokratischen
Werten gestern legte die israelische
Armee einen Untersuchungsbericht vor am
15 Dezember waren junge Männer die von
den Hamas Terroristen aus ihrem kibut
entführt worden waren von der
israelischen Armee erschossen worden die
sei versehentlich passiert die Sicht sei
schlecht gewesen die israelische Armee
übernehme die volle Verantwortung wir
haben den Familien die Ergebnisse der
Untersuchungen vorgelegt die uns zur
Verfügung standen für den Bericht haben
wir transparent die Wahrheit gesucht
auch wenn sie schwierig und schmerzhaft
ist unterdessen ist die humanitäre
Situation der Menschen im Gazastreifen
weiterhin kritisch wie hier im
Flüchtlingslager dir albalach Hunger
Kälte Tod
allgegenwärtig ich habe meine Kinder
beerdigt meine Söhne 16 und 18 Jahre es
ist nicht zu fassen die eigenen Kinder
zu beerdigen im Morgengrauen ich dachte
sie würden eines Tages mich
beerdigen
187 Menschen sollen allein gestern nach
Angaben der Hamas bei Angriffen des
israelischen Militärs getötet worden
sein auch heute gingen die Einsätze
vermindert weiter besonders um die Stadt
chanonis wo die israelische Armee die
Führungsspitze der Hamas
vermutet in der serbischen Hauptstadt
Belgrad blockieren heute Studenten eine
wichtige Straßenkreuzung aus Protest
gegen mutmaßlichen Wahlbetrug bei der
Parlamentswahl die hatte die rechte
Regierungspartei von Präsident wuic
gewonnen 24 Stunden wollen die
Demonstranten den Verkehr lahm legen sie
fordern dass die Wählerverzeichnisse
überprüft werden internationale
Beobachter berichteten von verschiedenen
Unregelmäßigkeiten bei der Wahl unter
anderem von Stimmenkauf und
Gewalt dieses nachrichtenjahr ist
geprägt durch Krisen die Kriege in der
Ukraine und Nahost die schlechten
wirtschaftsch Wirtschaftszahlen der
dauernde Streit in der Regierung
verblüffenderweise
entwickelt sich der Aktienmarkt aber
gerade zu prächtig martin wolseffer hat
mehr im ewigen Duell auf dem Paket hat
sich eh hier im Jahr 2023 deutlich
durchgesetzt der Bulle Symbol für
steigende Kurse dabei hatten die
wenigsten damit gerechnet dass der DAX
20% zulegt ein Grund dafür an der Börse
werden Erwartungen gehandelt also die
Zukunft man geht im nächsten Jahr davon
aus dass sowohl in USA als auch in
Europa die Zinsen wieder gesenkt werden
und das schürt h die Hoffnung und das
treibt hier auch die Kurse erste Stimmen
aus dem ezbrrat überlegen ar den
leidzins schon im Frühjahr zu senken um
Investitionsanreize zu schaffen doch
manche volkswerte halten das für zu früh
es gebe weiterhin Risiken warnt etwa jör
Krämer es ist wichtig dass die
Europäische Zentralbank diesem Druck
nicht nachgibt sondern die Zinsen
möglichst lange auf dem Niveau behält
denn das inflationsproblem im Euroraum
ist noch lange nicht gelöst Gewinner in
diesem Jahr Technologieunternehmen viele
Anleger setzen große Hoffnung in die
künstliche Intelligenz lief es dagegen
in der Chemie und der Pharmabranche sie
kämpfen unter anderem mit weiter hohen
Energiekosten und nächstes Jahr da
blicken die Märkte vor allem auf die
US-Wahl und das mögliche Comeback Donald
Trumps wie sieht es mit seiner
Unterstützung für die NATO aus unsere
Verteidigungsfähigkeit vor dem
Hintergrund eines aggressiv auftretenden
Russlands also da sind wichtige Fragen
die im kommenden Jahr an den Börsen auch
eine große Rolle spielen werden wer im
nächsten Jahr gewinnt bulle oder Bär
Ausgang wie immer offen
ja jetzt bist du dann Rudi mit
erfreulichen Nachrichten vom skialpin
skialpin es geht auf die Piste zunächst
einen Erfolg zum Jahresabschluss feiert
Skirennläuferin Lena Dürr beim Sieg der
Amerikanerin Mikaela schifffrin belegt
die Münchnerin beim Weltcup Slalom in
liens in Österreich Rang
2 nur die allesüberragende Mikaela
schifffrin ist schneller als die
32-Jährige deutsche während die
usamerikanerin mit Bestzeiten in beiden
Läufen die Konkurrenz dominiert steigert
sich Lena im zweiten durch noch einmal
glänzt mit einer fehlerfreien Fahrt und
verbessert sich von Platz 5 auf Rang 2
mit ihrem dritten Podestplatz bleibt sie
die einzig erfolgreiche Athletin der
alpinen in dieser
Saison
gerbrin price aus Wales Weltmeister von
2021 ist bei der darzwm überraschend
ausgeschieden auch der letzte deutsche
Ricardo pietrezko unterlag in London
einem Favoriten der sich erstmal gar
nicht richtig freuen
konnte Wut über eine Gruppe unfairer
deutscher Fans musste Luke humfrees erst
einmal herauslassen danach nahm er die
Glückwünsche des nur
hauchdünngeschlagenen deutschen Ricardo
pietrezko entgegen bei jedem Wurf war
der Engländer ausgepfiffen
worden dennoch gab pietrezko seine 3 Z1
Führung noch aus der Hand hampfries
bewies Nervenstärke und siegte mit 4:3
nachdem wie er sagte härtesten Spiel
seiner Karriere
[Musik]
so und das war schon der kurze Sport
heute danke schön Rudi und zum Schluss
noch ein Blick ins allgu dort haben sich
hunderte Kinder aus ganz Deutschland in
Schale geworfen verkleidet als die
heiligen drei Könige kasperar melchor
und balterasar reisten sie zum
Eröffnungsgottesdienst der
Sternsingeraktion dafür sammeln jedes
Jahr rund 300.000 Kinder Spenden diesmal
für den Regenwald und die Menschen im
Amazonasgebiet zuletzt kamen dabei mehr
als
Millionen Euro
zusammen heute Nacht soll es noch mal
teilskräftig regnen morgen gibt's dann
eine kurze Regenpause die Details hat
gleich Christa Orben Christian Sievers
begrüßt sie um 22 Uhr im heute journal
und wir sind morgen wieder da ich
wünsche Ihnen noch einen unbeschwerten
Abend auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen
guten Abend 2023 war das wärmste Jahr
seit Aufzeichnungsbeginn und das sechst
nasseste morgen gibt es jetzt aber eine
kurze Regenpause die einen Tiefs ziehen
ab das andere erreicht uns erst am
Sonntag das heißt bei uns fällt kaum
etwas bis dahin aber also heute Nacht
kann es zwischen Münsterland und
Oderbruch also auch in den
hochwasserregion durchaus noch mal
kräftiger regnen vor allem in kurzen
Gewittern im Süden Verlauf verläuft die
Nacht meist trocken an den Alpen sinken
die Werte auf 2° sonst auf 8 bis 4°
morgen erreichen die Temperaturen auf
Rügen und im Erzgebirge 6° am oberrein
13° es ist also ein recht milder und
auch recht freundlicher Tag meist ist es
trocken und es gibt durchaus auch Sonne
nur einzelne Schauer sind unterwegs z.B
in der östlichen Mitte oder an der Küste
abends dann im Nordwesten und dazu wird
ein frischer Böger Wind aus westlichen
Richtungen zum Jahreswechsel rückt dann
aber der Regen aus West wieder in den
Fokus für sich genommen sind die Summen
an Silvester und an neuahr nicht ganz so
hoch aber das summiert sich über die
Tage dann eben doch und Vorsicht ab der
Nacht auf Dienstag sind nach aktuellem
Stand auch wieder stark und
dauerregenfälle möglich wir behalten das
für sie im Auge
tschüss